the world's top Pros including those
from the Breakaway Saudi tour are ready
to go at Augusta National Golf Club so
is five-time Champion Tiger Woods who
said this week he doesn't know how many
more Masters he can play senior National
correspondent Jim Axelrod is there too
Jim good morning
well good morning Nate no shortage of
story lines here at the Masters you got
tiger you got Rory you got tensions with
golfers from the Saudi backlib golf
league but perhaps nothing is creating
more anxiety here at Augusta National
nothing more than the weather forecast
it's a shame the folks who run the
Masters can't put the Glorious weather
of the last 24 hours in the bank
because they may need it oh there's
plenty of questions as the 87th Masters
gets underway you know I'm feeling as
sort of relaxed as I ever have coming in
here can Rory McIlroy finally win here
and complete the career Grand Slam he's
over 14 at the Masters you know you have
to learn from those challenges and learn
from some of that scar tissue that's
built up and what would a masters be
without the tiger factor I think my game
is is better than it was last year at
this particular time better than last
year when Tiger Woods thrilled everyone
just 14 months after a horrible car
crash to be able to come here and play
at Augusta National it's it's such a a
special place and it means so much to me
in my heart to be able to come here I
don't know how many more I have in me I
want it so much like it would lightning
would have to strike again but it's
tiger so you never know best-selling
golf writer Alan shipnuck is also
keeping his sharp eye on the 18 live
golfers teeing off his latest book
detailed Phil Mickelson's decision to
jump to the saudi-backed league which
started a rivalry that has split the
golf world for live guy wins that's
going to be a huge deal in this whole
narrative and I would actually welcome
it because there's been so there's been
so much conversation about have these
guys sold out it's like it would end all
that conversation if a live guy wins and
I think that would be welcomed but the
biggest question this morning is will
the rain forecast for the next three
days swamp the tournament it's really
Friday Saturday I'm worried about we
could see a thunderstorm Friday that
risk is definitely going to be a factor
when you think about people wait their
entire lives to come to this tournament
and then this is the forecast so it's
not great Riley Hale was the chief
meteorologist at News 12 our CBS Augusta
station WRDW let me put you on the spot
they're going to get the tournament done
by Sunday fingers crossed I don't want
to jinx it but I think so
it's been 40 years since the Masters
have seen a Monday finish due to bad
weather that was 1983 sebi balosteros
was the winner and it is safe to say
that everyone here at Augusta National
is hoping to keep that streak alive for
yet another year Nate
the only weather I'm worried about is
whether I'll be watching from the
bedroom or the couch Jim thank you